[Música]
buenos días señor ministro gracias por
recibir a france 24 y radio france
internacional en el cuadro en el
ministerio de asuntos exteriores me
acompaña christophe barbier te refiero
días buenos días señor ministro
en ucrania los rusos anunciaron ayer que
iban a reducir drásticamente su
actividad militar en torno a kiev
eternit y al mismo tiempo hay
negociaciones en curso en turquía que
parecen avanzar hace unos meses señor
ministro dijo que lo peor estaba por
llegar esos temas optimista hoy de algún
avance
en la medida en que por el momento la
guerra continúa leo palabras leo
declaraciones no veo acciones que yo
sepa no se ha tomado ninguna medida de
retirada con respecto a la ocupación de
las fuerzas armadas rusas en ucrania
la guerra continúa en kiev anoche hubo
bombardeos
la guerra continúa en jarquín la guerra
continúa el mariupol que se está
convirtiendo en una ciudad mártir donde
el asedio a mar y un por decidido por el
presidente putin ha provocado que más de
200.000 personas permanezcan como
rehenes la guerra continúa y por el
momento no hay que yo sepa ninguna
novedad
usted se refiere a las declaraciones ha
habido muchas declaraciones de las
autoridades rusas de forma muy variables
y por el momento no cree en rusia
creer en las acciones y si mañana por la
mañana el presidente putin dice como
señal de mi voluntad de rearticulación
de reorganización
renunció al asedio de mariupol permito
que la ayuda humanitaria entre el
mariupol permitió a la población civil
de mariupol moverse libremente entonces
diré si hay progreso y también diré si
tal vez lo peor ya pasó pero hoy no hay
actos usted dice como bling en el
secretario de estado estadounidense que
está lo que rusia dice es lo que hace
así que no confía realmente en vladimir
putin la confianza son las acciones la
confianza siempre han sido acciones por
el momento no están presentes es ingenuo
creer en un alto el fuego
tiene que haber un alto al fuego pero el
alto al fuego no se decreta es una
decisión política del presidente putting
de decir ok paramos y negociamos por el
momento este no es el caso más vale
hablar de negociaciones es cierto que
hay acontecimientos en torno a las
negociaciones en estambul pero las
conversaciones ya llevan tres semanas de
negociaciones en belarús en gómel
también se negoció una parte en otro
lugar negociaciones sobre el mismo tema
con menos espectacularidad pero de
momento no se ha avanzado nada en ningún
tema esa es la realidad por tanto no
debemos dejarnos ilusionar por las
declaraciones necesitamos acciones si
rusia quiere realmente que creamos en
ella debería poner acciones sobre la
mesa y demostrar concretamente esta
nueva orientación si es que la hay
pero no aflojarán los rusos del dominio
que ejercen sobre quiere tal vez para
desplegarse más hacia el este de ucrania
en el donbass y así salir del norte para
tener más presencia en el este
ya veremos por el momento son sólo
anuncios señaló que quien fue
bombardeada anoche no teme una
concentración rusa en el donbass
es posible que dada las circunstancias
que tiene el ejército ruso en ucrania se
reevalúen los planes pero también es
posible que este período en el que se
anuncian discusiones más profundas sea
un período en que rusia aproveche para
reconstruir sus fuerzas porque la
estrategia de la guerra de asedio que es
la estrategia que rusia está aplicando
hoy el asedio bajar el asedio a mariupol
hablando de eso lo habían predicho si
dije que sería una guerra de ascendió
las guerras de asedios son terribles
tenemos una historia de guerras de
asedio la historia es tanto la de grozny
como la de alepo pienso en alepo porque
yo estaba a cargo en ese momento mismo
que rusia dijo vamos a negociar y luego
la realidad fue que reconstituyeron las
fuerzas así que ya veremos si el
discurso que se plantea se manifiesta en
acciones concretas
ya sea en retiradas o en el anuncio de
un alto al fuego lo que se necesita hoy
es el anuncio de un alto el fuego el
mariupol para evitar la carnicería
porque lo que está ocurriendo al
mariupol es espantoso por lo tanto la
responsabilidad de lo que va a ocurrir
en mariupol es de rúsia
usted habla de las negociaciones para
abordar las cuestiones militares y
diplomáticas por primera vez dijo
durante las últimas tres semanas las
negociaciones han avanzado su crean ya
no renunciarían a la idea de entrar en
la ota y aceptarían un estatus neutral
pero a condición de que grandes países
como francia garanticen su seguridad así
que en concreto señor ministro que
significa ser garante porque discúlpeme
pero suena muy parecido al artículo 5
del tratado de la otan que dice un
ataque contra uno es un ataque contra
todos
usted dijo que las negociaciones han
avanzado
son estables pero en cualquier caso en
términos de comunicación
quiero dejar una cosa clara las
negociaciones son los mismos temas que
han discutido regularmente las
delegaciones rusas y ucranianas durante
tres semanas con un avance un acto
político importante que fue tomado por
el presidente de zielinski quien dijo
estoy de acuerdo en que debemos trabajar
en un concepto de neutralidad de ucrania
pero al mismo tiempo digo que va más
allá de la neutralidad cuyo contenido
debe ser definido lo que no es el caso
en este momento debe haber garantías de
seguridad lo que es normal así que
pensemos en estas garantías de seguridad
pero por el momento no se aceptan ni el
primer ni el segundo principio sí pero
tal vez deberíamos pensar ya en lo que
significa ser garante estamos totalmente
dispuestos a trabajar con el presidente
excelencia y como él sabe en la forma de
ofrecer garantías pero el problema es
que debe haber negociaciones reales y
quizás también sería conveniente que el
presidente de silenci se reuniera con el
presidente putin por el momento esto no
es posible porque el presidente putin se
niega
y no pediría el presidente s lens que
estas garantías de seguridad para crimea
y el donbass es decir que tal vez en el
futuro se pueda contemplar una
reincorporación de esas dos regiones a
rusia y que tal vez esto permita
arreglar la situación no voy a negociar
por los ucranianos son los ucranianos
quienes deben negociar con rusia
conocemos los temas de negociación en
realidad garantías nivel de
desmilitarización de ucrania territorio
el estatus del donbass y la cuestión de
crimea además la necesidad de un alto al
fuego cuando la necesidad de una agenda
para la retirada gradual de las fuerzas
rusas ese es todo el paquete de
negociación pero desde hace tres semanas
es todo eso y por el momento a parte del
presidente selenski la única iniciativa
fuerte que se ha tomado es aquella en la
que anunció su voluntad de asegurar que
ucrania se convierte en un país neutral
la única iniciativa fuerte que se ha
tomado es aquella en la que anunció su
voluntad de asegurar que ucrania se
convierte en un país neutral
no es ingenuo señor ministro hablar de
neutralidad cuando se está rodeado por
rusia que sus vecinos son los rusos
y
de ahí la necesidad de garantías y por
lo tanto la necesidad de negociar y no
se negocia con una pistola en la cabeza
de ahí la necesidad de un alto al fuego
por otro lado si hay una modificación de
la constitución ucraniana porque para
decir neutralidad hay que decir
referéndum se puede realizar un
referéndum en ucrania cuando las fuerzas
rusas están presentes en el territorio o
no así que tenemos que negociar por el
momento todo esto no ha comenzado
esperemos que progrese será un proceso
largo y dura necesitan hacer
todos necesitamos un alto al fuego va a
llevar mucho tiempo pero como saber
cuáles pueden ser los parámetros
en cualquier caso el presidente
ucraniano ya tiene algunas ideas sobre
el tema hay que hablar si también con el
presidente putin de ahí la necesidad de
garantizar un vínculo permanente con el
presidente putin razón por la cual el
presidente macrón habla a menudo con él
por teléfono para mantener un canal de
diálogo y garantizar que llegado al
momento podamos hablar en profundidad
espero que este momento sea rápidamente
y que evitemos la carnicería de mariupol
que hace el presidente más con cuando
tiene al presidente putin al teléfono
en general no creo
y los puntos de vista se suelen exponer
con claridad normalmente con gran
claridad por ambas partes vuelven a
hablar hay poco progreso pero al menos
hay un canal potencial de conversación
el presidente de macrón también habla
con el presidente putin a veces con el
canciller alemán
entonces el presidente putting debe
darse cuenta de que tiene dos
interlocutores en esta discusión que
están dispuestos a fomentar el diálogo
pero que también son firmes en cuanto a
la soberanía de ucrania el que rechaza
el hecho de que un estado ataque a otro
estado como está sucediendo ahora con
todo el dolor y el sufrimiento que esto
impone al pueblo
usted dijo que los turcos son quizás una
buena noticia en este terrible flagelo
los turcos están en el centro de la
mediación y emanuel mcconnie erdogán
hablaron recientemente
terminó la disputa entre turquía y
francia
cuando se trata de salvar vidas de hacer
posible la paz y de detener el dramático
proceso al que nos enfrentamos dejamos
las asperezas de lado tratamos de hacer
que las cosas avancen y toda buena
voluntad es bienvenida
el secretario general de la otan jens
stoltenberg afirma que todavía es
posible que rusia recurra el uso de
armas químicas físicos esto tendría
enormes consecuencias confirma esto le
teme a esto
si rusia utiliza estas armas no
convencionales debe esperar sanciones
masivas muy fuertes ellos saben ya se
los hemos dicho así que deben tener en
cuenta estos riesgos
pero ya vimos en 2013 como cuando se
usaron armas químicas en síria todo el
mundo los estadounidenses se hicieron
los de la vista gorda no le da miedo que
vuelva a ocurrir lo mismo
creo que el presidente putin se ha dado
cuenta de una cosa de la unidad y la
firmeza de la unión europea de todos los
países y de la relación transatlántica
de la solidez de la alianza
y también de la voluntad de todos estos
países de ayudar a ucrania con mucha
firmeza tanto a través de sanciones como
de apoyo financiero pero también
mediante la entrega de equipo militar él
lo sabe por lo tanto es él quien debe
evaluar los riesgos pero esa es su
responsabilidad no la nuestra
entrega de equipo militar incluso por
parte de francia si incluso francia
suministramos equipos militares
defensivos pero letales a ucrania
nosotros y luego casi todos los países
europeos
equipos letales sí por supuesto
y si se utilizan armas químicas que hay
que hacer intensificar las sanciones
como dice boris johnson
si no les voy a dar la respuesta
pero sí
digo sanciones fuertes y masivas no voy
a describirlas
sobre el drama de mariupol es imposible
convencer a vladimir putin de que haga
este corredor humanitario incluso en eso
no quiere ceder
mensaje del partido
con el concepto de corredor humanitario
al estilo ruso es un concepto particular
que encaja en la lógica de la guerra de
asedio lo experimentamos en grozny lo
experimentamos en alepo y ahora tenemos
esta experiencia el mariupol es decir
les dejamos un corredor humanitario lo
que pase por el corredor humanitario
llegará a rusia y los que no se van son
considerados terroristas o nazis porque
se utilizó ese término
entonces es un pretexto adicional para
reforzar los bombardeos esta es la
lógica militar de los corredores
humanitarios al estilo ruso lo que
queremos en mariupol es un alto al fuego
el levantamiento del asedio y la libre
circulación de la ayuda humanitaria y de
las personas en mariupol y esta es la
cuestión del momento y no debemos
dejarnos engañar por las declaraciones
rusas cuando la realidad es el drama de
mariupol en este momento
es posible que manuel ma con viaje a
kiev o a moscú a moscú
la nutria en el foso qué
ya se ha demostrado con creces que las
iniciativas de paz se tomaron cuando fue
necesario con los riesgos necesarios
lo demostró yendo a moscú tal y como
están las cosas la cuestión no se
plantea puede plantearse pero por el
momento no es un tema actual
desde el inicio de la guerra la unión
europea está muy unida pero alemania
depende mucho más del gas ruso que
francia
no existe el riesgo de que esta bella
unidad se rompa por el tema de las
sanciones y el embargo
whitman que la gran novedad es que la
europa de hoy no es la misma que
funcionaba antes del 24 de febrero la
gran noticia es que hubo un consejo
europeo excepcional en versalles que
ratificó la llamada agenda de versalles
en la que los europeos decidieron juntos
adquirir la autonomía energética lo
antes posible con etapas pero lo antes
posible esto implica también asegurar el
fortalecimiento de la transición
energética adaptada a la lucha contra el
cambio climático para no depender de los
combustibles fósiles rusos y este
movimiento se aplicará a partir de este
año se continuará para tener propuestas
sostenibles y esto concierne a todos los
países incluida alemania que apoyó esta
propuesta
es necesario buscar otros socios esta es
la primera parte de mi pregunta usted
estuvo en doha en qatar donde anunció
que estábamos de un acuerdo sobre la
cuestión nuclear iraní cuando dice cerca
cuenta en días meses semanas que es lo
que sigue deteniendo a teherán y a
washington
j
el mayor avance en relación con la
cuestión nuclear iraní es que estamos
sobre la base de un acuerdo en cuanto a
los acuerdos de viena que en términos
técnicos se denominan 'el país'
significa que irán está dispuesto a
renunciar a la adquisición de armas
nucleares y que se levantarán las
sanciones que estaban vinculadas a la
carrera de irán por adquirir armas
nucleares
estamos de acuerdo con el contenido
cuando digo nosotros me refiero a todos
es decir los europeos irán rusia china y
eeuu que ya no es parte del acuerdo pero
que dieron su consentimiento
así que la firma es inminente
y sería muy bueno que no añadiéramos una
crisis de proliferación nuclear a la
guerra que existe hoy en día en contra
sigue habiendo un bloqueo que no está
vinculado a este acuerdo que es
independiente que está vinculado a la
relación entre eeuu e irán sobre otros
temas sobre otro tema concreto
espero que podamos resolver este asunto
porque entonces firmaremos
inmediatamente
esta visión
existe el riesgo de hambruna en algunos
países del sur con la gravísima
perturbación del mercado de cereales y
que puede hacer francia hay reservas que
puede hacer francia para evitar la
hambruna
y ya sabes que real
existe un riesgo real de escasez de
alimentos sobre todo de cereales tanto
de trigo como de maíz y girasol ya que
ucrania es un gran productor y hoy en
día es difícil cultura sin
el riesgo también se debe a que la
logística y el transporte son ahora muy
difíciles tanto para ucrania como para
rusia
y también en este caso no debemos
dejarnos engañar por el discurso que
sostienen hoy los rusos según el cual si
mañana hay riesgo de hambruna es por
culpa de las sanciones no es debido a
las sanciones es debido a la ocupación
rusa de ucrania
y no se cultiva en presencia de fuerzas
militares no es posible así que hay
grandes temores sobre la seguridad
alimentaria en algunos países estoy
pensando en los países de oriente medio
y áfrica en particular
además la iniciativa que el presidente
de la república tomó en la reunión del
g7 en bruselas la semana pasada se llama
operación farm que consiste en tomar
iniciativas en tres áreas diferentes
en primer lugar en el ámbito de la
comercialización para que haya más
transparencia más fluidez en el mercado
evitar el almacenamiento evitar la
especulación con los cereales
especulación sobre se real
mecanismos de solidaridad para
garantizar que los países con mayores
dificultades puedan ser apoyados con
entregas especialmente de trigo
[Música]
hay que almacenar lo que queda de las
existencias es esta también la pregunta
y que permitamos que el programa mundial
de alimentos haga su trabajo y que no
esté sujeto a la especulación y al
almacenamiento para que pueda distribuir
y también para producir más todos los
países son alentados a hacerlo este
tríptico es importante fue iniciado por
francia pero es retomado por la unión
europea para que seamos totalmente
solidarios y evitemos estos riesgos que
no se presentarán mañana pero si pasado
mañana
señor ministro vamos a hablar de mali
los soldados de barkhan se fueron
después de nueve años de presencia 58
soldados franceses perdieron la vida los
yihadistas siguen allí incluso ganarán
terreno tiene un sentimiento de amargura
habiendo vivido desde separ has abarcar
un sentimiento de desprecio y una forma
de impotencia
más que un papel su fan
iniciativa del celular las comoras idi
buscan
proteger
es accionista
el desperdicio es político porque a
menudo recordamos la iniciativa serbal
en aquel momento y luego barkan para
prevenir las acciones terroristas de los
grupos organizados y debemos recordarles
a los espectadores que los grupos
terroristas son tanto el estado islámico
como al qaeda no son grupos informales
son grupos que tienen resonancias
organizaciones que están acostumbrados a
las herramientas del combate que llevan
a cabo e hicimos lo correcto en aquel
momento para proteger a mali hicimos
bien porque lo que está en juego es y
siempre fue la soberanía y la integridad
de manish la fecha a la que más me
refiero es 2015 los acuerdos de argel
porque hay una base hay una solución
hubo negociaciones hubo discusiones que
llevaron a estos acuerdos que los
dirigentes malienses por muchas razones
no quisieron aplicar
estos acuerdos de argel se basan en la
descentralización el desarme de los
grupos armados firmantes su inclusión en
las fuerzas armadas o policiales
malienses y en el desarrollo las tres de
descentralización desarme y desarrollo
el principio del inicio era apenas
visible
pero existe este texto que está
garantizado en primer lugar por las
autoridades argelinas que son las
garantes de este acuerdo hablamos antes
de garantías las autoridades argelinas
tienen la responsabilidad de aplicar
estos acuerdos pero por el momento no
hay respuesta además
los acuerdos de argel también
permitieron la presencia de fuerzas de
la onu en territorio maliense para
garantizar su aplicación eso está sobre
la mesa
desde hace dos meses señor ministro los
militares malienses y los supuestos
milicianos del grupo ruso wagner han
sido considerados responsables por las
naciones unidas se suman rights watch de
graves abusos en el centro de mali
confirma esta información o no
y
todos los elementos que tenemos
incluidas las ong que han investigado el
tema incluida las naciones unidas-
demuestran que al final la presencia de
wagner en mali se trata de abusos y de
la limitación de la libertad pública
ustedes saben
la suspensión de las emisiones de rf y
france24
sí por supuesto ese nuevo autoritarismo
que hace que la agenda en el poder sea
un poco rehén en estos puntos por la
fuerza va a tener entonces wagner que
tenía fama de ser una fuerza de
liberación es ahora una fuerza de abusos
y depredación además se están utilizando
los propios recursos de malísimos eso es
muy grave
el tiempo se agota hace dos meses el
embajador francés en bamako fue
expulsado por las autoridades malienses
que le acusan de conspirar contra ellas
se ha roto todo el diálogo con bamako o
emmanuel macrón está en contacto con el
jefe de la junta maliense el coronel así
militar
los coroneles y me costó el segundo
demonio
este gobierno no tiene legitimidad es un
gobierno que salió de un golpe de estado
y es un gobierno que por el momento no
está poniendo en marcha las formas de
reconocimiento legítimo que podría tener
el pueblo maliense
estamos trabajando con la cedeao que
organiza a todos los estados de la
región para luchar contra el terrorismo
porque lo que va a ocurrir es una
rearticulación completa de los
dispositivos franceses y europeos
la decisión de rearticularse de
posicionarse y reorganizarse fue tomada
de forma conjunta por europeos y
africanos el pasado mes de febrero para
organizarse de forma diferente y que
realmente hay una reorganización
y también para dar mayor alcance a
nuestra acción conjunta en apoyo de las
distintas autoridades de los países
afectados por la amenaza terrorista
no sólo en los países del sahel sino
ahora también los países del golfo de
guinea porque estamos viendo avances una
porosidad de la acción de los grupos
terroristas en el norte de estos países
entonces francia va a volver a
desplegarse en níger el pasado mes de
noviembre hubo una violenta
manifestación anti francesa entera al
paso de un convoy militar de la
operación marcan hubo tres muertos entre
los manifestantes no ocurre ni xerez el
riesgo de encontrarse con el mismo
problema que malí es decir con el
sentimiento antifrancés
no no va a ser así en absoluto
francia no va a volver a desplegarse en
níjar lo que acabo de decir es que
nosotros estamos reorganizando juntos
cuando digo no me refiero a los europeos
y a los africanos para que se respeten
los cuatro pilares de lo que llamamos
los acuerdos de yamena es decir la lucha
contra el terrorismo la formación de las
fuerzas militares de los países
implicados el retorno del estado a las
zonas reconquistadas y el desarrollo el
próximo lunes iré a madrid para asistir
a la tercera reunión de la alianza del
sahel para movilizar fondos para esos
países vamos a organizarnos en función
de las necesidades y peticiones de cada
uno de los estados afectados
ya sea en el sahel o en los estados del
golfo de guinea con respuestas variables
según los distintos países en
solidaridad con los africanos y los
europeos no es que francia se vaya a
reinstalar en níger no es eso en níger
habrá una petición si habrá presidencia
francesa
europea europea europea
gracias señor ministro por concedernos
esta entrevista y gracias a ustedes por
habernos visto
[Música]